I'm John levenshtein and today we're
going to be talking about Wayne wheeler
the man responsible for prohibition
Cheers
cheers John Wayne wheeler would have
hated that wayne wheeler's family had a
farmhand who was drunk who was swaying a
pitchfork to Hayfork wildly he said mom
that farmhands acting sloppy the
farmhand stabs Wayne wheeler in the leg
Wayne wheeler said ouch
hey yeah what are you doing you just
stabbed me in the leg
what are you drunk you farmhand Wayne
wheeler decided alcohol is bad I'm going
to spend the rest of my life fighting
against alcohol and that's the for the
formative event of wayne wheeler's wife
with a okay the okay though the
formative event of wayne wheeler's
life Wayne wheeler in 1893 graduated
from college he goes to see Howard Hyde
Russell from the anti-saloon league
speak I'm against alcohol I'm against
the way alcohol affects the American
family men should not drink at the
saloon waste away their family's money
come home hit their wives hit their fur
then that shouldn't happen after the
speech he said I'm going to join your
movement and I'll devote my life to
making people not drink now Wayne
wheeler would the anti-saloon League was
a dynamo he was just biking everywhere
he was biking from town to town going
door-to-door getting people to vote
against
candidates who opposed prohibition and
when Willer would say people shouldn't
drink I was sat by a pitchfork and I was
a child and then they would say oh
people can be stabbed by pitchforks as
children and when Willer would say yes
[Music]
why'd you laugh because I was seeing two
of you Wayne wheeler was going to
churches to raise money he was going to
arrange demonstrations and he was always
on his bike he was always peddling
furiously Wayne wheeler
invented pressure politics when wheeler
would say this person is not strongly
enough in favor of temperance then that
person would go down every time seventy
four seventy so Wayne wheeler comes to
Washington DC and starts fighting for a
constitutional amendment against alcohol
everyone is afraid of Wayne wheeler
Wayne wheeler is the most successful
lobbyist in the United States there was
another thing that happened that I'm
forgetting right now so I'll get that
I'll get back to that I'll get back to
Derek but in the meantime prohibition
was passed and Wayne wheeler won the day
Wayne wheeler was such a zealot because
once prohibition happened that wasn't
enough for Wayne wheeler he goes to see
the head of the KKK I'm a national
figure I can't do my own bidding but you
Ku Klux Klan
and so the ku klux rented it they were
wayne wheeler's private security force
and they would go into bars and just
tear the place apart the ku klux ad was
a violent organization they were tarring
and feathering people who were
bootleggers wayne wheeler's great name
Wayne wheeler Wayne wheeler is so crazy
because there was still industrial
alcohol that was used to clean engine
parts to make nail polish Wayne wheeler
said we need to find a way to make that
legal alcohol poisonous we're going to
add methanol to ethanol call it formula
number 30 and then anyone who drinks
ethanol not to clean engines but to get
drunk will die and that's when this hit
the fan people who are drinking ethanol
mixed with methanol didn't know that
that's what they were doing it made
thousands of people sick and hundreds of
people died and Wayne wheeler Singh
what's your own fault
you know about prohibition you know
alcohol is illegal you're dead now and
people started thinking why would my own
government do this to me Wayne wheeler
who had been pretty much running the
government as a lobbyist was discredited
and that's when he went to Michigan and
then died a few weeks later just because
Wayne wheeler was stabbed in the leg by
a pitchfork but drunken farmhand as a
he had to spend the rest of his life
making sure no one else had fun no
matter what
oh you got it I love that you're
collecting the ice all right
this is as drunk as I get
you